the Emmys the nominees have been
announced and the Emmys have gone full
social justice worry if you look at this
list it is basically a who's who of
social justice warrior shows actors
contributors writers to the point where
this is actually good
they've overreached so much that Bill
Nyes sexual spectrum episode was
nominated for outstanding writing in a
non fiction series outstanding
exceptional exemplary some would say why
are you talking about this why does it
just doesn't matter who cares no no
actually this does because up until
recently the Emmys the Oscars these were
some of the most watched events yes and
now people hopefully and we'll get into
exactly why this is the case with the
Emmys some information that you may not
have known I think people are waking up
to the fact that it's actually a
propaganda tool absolutely that's all is
is one big propaganda machine to try and
push a social political message of the
day and if you look at their board
members you look at their history it is
clear as day so first off let's let's
get into how can you prove motive here
well who determines the Emmys so it's
the Academy of Television Arts and
Sciences okay and it's a symbol of peer
recognition the Academy has over 22,000
members divided into 30 peer groups and
specialized fields the members of each
peer group vote in the nominees and
winners four categories pertaining to a
particular area of specialty here's
something to know that the huge majority
of people who are on their staff are not
only Democrats but outright Clinton
donors or supporters yeah if you look
here they are proactively giving all of
their money to the Clintons and this is
why this this matters is because it
dispels this this idea of talent over
agenda yeah we saw with Samantha bee
last week they're going well we don't
really have an agenda we just tell the
truth
it's about what's important right that's
exactly that's the term they use all the
time to port what do what he talked
about in Porton with combat is it funny
it's important what do you mean Samantha
be funny she's important to have as a
host sir I said important well why was
it important this it's it's time you
it's funny I mean it's time for
importance I thought comedy was like one
way or the other so their chair just to
give you an idea their chair of this
this Academy is the chief executive
officer of the Institute that promotes
gender and diversity representation so
Madeline Dean Anna let's bring this up
as a chief executive officer at the
Geena Davis Institute on gender in media
the only research based non-profit
working in the entertainment industry to
systematically improve gender and
diversity representation in children's
entertainment so I don't even know what
that means but this is basically their
head of the people determining the Emmys
is also the head of ensuring that that
gender identity politics are played out
appropriately and fairly in children's
programming we have more to get to but
maybe now you're starting to see just
why they nominated this as outstanding
[Music]
host and outstanding
standing now I get it the Geena Davis
Institute by the way again their chair
has also done talks at events sponsored
directly by the Clinton Foundation this
is the person who's the head of the
Academy with the Emmys it shouldn't come
as a surprise that the Institute has
also promoted not only Hillary Clinton
but Chelsea Clinton on Twitter and
actively consistently pushed for
transgender policies so here's here's
kind of the issue is is this bigotry of
low expectations that you see from the
left but you see this in the
entertainment industry where it's a
standard of low expectations as long as
you meet the political threshold as long
as you meet the agenda threshold and the
reason this matters is because for a
long time Awards just like grants just
like scholarships just like going to the
best schools it was supposed to be a
meritocracy in the United States you won
the soccer game because you scored the
goals not because you didn't want to
hurt the other team's feelings that's
how you won the award that's how your
shows did well by the way these awards
there's a huge discrepancy between the
shows that rack up the awards often and
people watching them that's another
important note there is such a
disconnect with the American pot and
some of it can be attributed to well
yeah 22,000 members in this they're
mostly going to lean left but every
single one to the point that the
nominees list is so remote the only
standard it seems that's consistent
there are other standards and sometimes
they're excellent programs that happen
to be left but the only standard
is consistent is that you have to at
least be left or somewhat neutral to be
allowed there is nothing nothing coming
from the right that's a lot in there
let me read you a list just not only
from this year we'll go throughout kind
of the history of it but this year we
have blackish of course Laverne Cox is
transgender from the orange is the new
black we have a different import for
transparent comedy actor you tell me if
I don't know a single person who watches
transparent every time he goes out and
accepts a comedy we're Jeffrey Tambor
talks about how beautiful the
transgender community is go out there
make a [ __ ] joke it's a comedy
samantha bee of course for variety talk
writing in a series john oliver of
course stephen colbert for their shows
alec baldwin for his trump SNL a
supporting actor in a comedy series now
people can correct me if i'm wrong here
because I did some research today and it
wasn't it's hard to find this I've only
seen this twice someone who's actually
not a cast member of a comedy show like
SNL being nominated for playing a role
and by the way Alec Baldwin plays it
very poorly mind you without the SNL
makeup his impression okay is doing this
it's marginally better than ben shapiro
without the makeup and I love Ben he's
just not an impressionist but there are
other shows I think on that show on
Comedy Central where someone does a
pretty good one there was someone on
redeye I think someone does a pretty
good one on this program but certainly
better than Alec Baldwin the only time
they've ever seen someone who wasn't an
active cast member on SNL Leslie Jones
is nominated as a cast member for I
think Supporting Actress is Alec Baldwin
as Trump and Tina Fey after she left SNL
as Sarah Palin which by the way for
those who don't remember she was the one
who created the quote I can see Russia
from my house and people thought Sarah
Palin said she never said it Tina Fey
said that once again shows you that
consider these are the only two times
I've been able to find throughout all of
Emmy history that this kind of an
exception has been able for a nomination
it's not based on quality it's based on
the political damage that can be
inflicted so we've already said Samantha
bee but a double nomination for Samantha
bees not the White House Correspondents
Dinner best directing in a variety
special Stephen Colbert again for his
live election night democracy's series
finale who's going to clean up this [ __ ]
again directing for a variety special
yeah the veep which is funny you have
inside Amy Schumer we have American
crime the Reagan Sea of Angels in
America which is about the AIDS epidemic
which never actually happened just don't
have gay sex and use intravenous drugs
without cleaning the needle and you're
fine not to mention Bill Nye saves the
world writing outstanding writing
non-fictional program so in other words
when you look throughout this you have
willing grace any on any given year I
want you to do this research right now
we have the links up we'll put it up at
ladder with better calm if you're
watching this on YouTube wherever you
are I want you to the research year to
year any year where there's a show with
the whiff of LGBTQA a IP or social
justice or implying that conservatives
are racist or doing damage to the
Republican Party whether it was the
Bush's during that era whether it was
Mitt Romney I think there was a
documentary too I think with Netflix
with I'm not entirely sure those
something I had to do with Romney when I
was looking through the list but any
given year if has even just a tinge of
this it gets nominated as a matter of
fact to not be nominated as a mainstream
liberal program on any of the networks
you would in fact have to be worse
because it wasn't you would have to be
worse than Bill Nyes sex episodes
do not be nominated you would have to be
worse than this versatile of may have
some blood stuff outstanding right by
the way you want and everyone has
different senses of humor I get it but
this is the episode that could have
single-handedly unraveled Bill Nyes
career when this happened on this
program we just ran the tape and laughed
our asses off we don't need to roll that
many clips it is so bad that when you
can just go watch and you don't need to
provide any commentary that's more
damning that's how bad something is and
maybe because they're so out of touch
again the activism the the the the the
donorship that you see the Democratic
Party they're working directly with the
Clinton Foundation they're working
directly with news organizations that
try to politically assassinate
conservatives look at the social justice
warriors whose whose list which usually
is not actually congruent with the shows
that people are watching when you add
all that up maybe that's why last year
they means had their lowest rated show
ever ever which may have came come as a
surprise none but that's why God they
plan to turn this ship around
so Fox my second set of n locks lock up
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit calm /
mug Club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than $6 a month and you get
daily content no more clips Plus this
hand at mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside